are you still in touch with Nick Carter
absolutely I just saw him perform last
night at the Saban theater he was
incredible
seriously just reminded me how talented
he is and I couldn't believe it I once
upon a time I was his fan girl with
Backstreet Boys and the next thing you
know I'm sitting in the audience I'm so
proud of this guy that I now call family
so it's just it's incredible ET was
exclusively with the Dancing with the
Stars Pro Sharna Burgess at the Vanity
Fair and L'Oreal deejay night event on
Friday where she opened up about her
former dance partner Nick Carter I want
to definitely do the best job I can for
Shauna she pushes me to to be the best
that I can be in January the Backstreet
Boy was arrested for his alleged
involvement in a bar scuffle in Key West
Florida Burgess says she's remained
supportive I text him straightaway as
soon as I heard and he told me you know
really what was going on and it's just
it's a shame that sometimes these things
get splashed all over the media and get
weighed out of proportion and taken the
wrong way he's such a good person but
he's surprised yeah absolutely when I
heard what the news was and then once I
heard his story then it all made a lot
of sense but you know he he's felt like
I said he's family to me so the minute I
heard I text him to make sure he was
okay and to get the true story because
you know you never know